[Music]
i'm going to show you how to get vgfx
rendering library set up on
a linux project using cmake for your
project
so welcome and uh
strap in because it's gonna be a bit of
a ride
vgfx is located on
github you can just go either to this
little site here you see
or you can just search for it it's bgfx
it's made by this guy and i'm not sure
how to pronounce his name
it's a very popular repo
it's known to be pretty stable and
useful and it's been used in quite a few
games
so if we scroll down i think he's got a
few screenshots somewhere yeah here we
go
the air mech was made with bgfx
cmft studio brown off-road legends
torque six
minecraft uses it buckle up
so once you're ready to start a project
and integrate
uh bgfx i would recommend doing it as a
sub module to do that
let's go ahead and open visual studio
code and we are using linux here
and we're just gonna go to open folder
and i'm just going to make a new folder
for this bgfx
project and okay
so what we have here is just an empty
folder and a brand new
project and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it with cmake
and to do this the way i'm doing it you
will need some add-ons mainly this
cmake from twxx the cmake from
microsoft and i'm using this
intellisense as well so
just in case you can't find the stuff
i'm using that's what i'm using
now you want to hit ctrl shift p and
look for c make
quick start and just click that click
your kit
give it a name vgfx project
library or executable we're going to be
making an executable
and there we go we don't need we're not
going to be using cpac in this
we're not going to be using c test all
we need is those three lines there
minimum required version project and add
executable
with our main so let's go ahead and add
in the bgfx stuff
first of all you need to initialize this
project with git
so you want to go to the terminal or
open a terminal however you want go to
this directory
and just do get and it initializes it
and to sub module this in you just got
to
type in a few commands so first of all
you want to go back to github and get
the directory
or get the uh link
you just go do that copy it i assume you
know how to clone it's sort of similar
to cloning except
we're going to be sub modulating instead
so now that i've got the link
and maybe i want to put them in a
certain folder or you can do them all in
the root
i'll show you how to put them on a
folder so we're just going to make a
folder here i'll just do a mixer
uh
sub mods i'm just called sub mods
so now we have a folder called sub mods
and say we want to put all these in here
so we do
get sub module
add paste in that repo
and then the path we want to save it to
so we're going to do
sub mods and then we're also going to
want to go in its own folder
bgfx so there we go
we hit that let it do its clone and in
sub mods it'll make a folder for bgfx
and we're going to do the same thing for
the other required libraries
which are going to be the x
and b image i'm not going to worry about
b net i guess i could i'll put b net in
there too why not
so we're just going to run the same
command again except this time
we're going to just call it bx
and it's almost the same directory just
bx.get
we'll grab that one
and b image
and we'll go ahead and grab the net too
because why not
however i'm not going to be doing
anything with bnet
okay now in our sub mods folder we have
all of those modules somewhat ready to
go
however they still need built and
included into the project
i'm going to show you how to do that now
so we're going to do one thing this is
something i covered in my cmake tutorial
episode 3 and about sub moduling and
that's just
a quick little command you can add to
your root level
you make to make sure whoever clones
your product
project downloads all the sub modules
and that is this command right here
[Music]
just that little set update sub modules
as needed and as you can see it just
runs the process
uh get sub module update and then
recursive
so it just runs that command it's a
module update in a recursive to grab all
your sub modules
and then you can do something to check
and make sure they exist
and we're going to want another one of
these or
b net they all use a make file
and we're putting them in the sub mods
folder so all this does is make sure
that the make file exists in that
directory which is
confirmation enough that we got it
downloaded if not it'll give you a fatal
error
all right so now what you need to do is
build them and you can
build them with a cmake command but it's
not recommended because it will do it
during your cmake configure
which is a little odd so i'd recommend
just doing it separately
and if you go look at the documentation
he shows you how to do all that
you just go to bgfx
look at the documentation
go to building over here and he
basically shows you what to do of course
you clone it
you can just clone it and build it all
i'm showing you with this sub module
example
and if you get totally stuck you can
always go back here you also want to
make sure you do the apt-get for
all these commands here so on linux
we basically want to do a make of the
version we want
so it should be pretty simple let's do a
make linux release 64.
and all you do is you go to your
terminal
change directory to
sub mods setup mods
pg fx
now basically this just wants those sub
libraries
bx uh bmh b net it wants them
in the same directory so as long as
you've put all these in the same
directory
this make will integrate those uh just
fine
let's just do a uh ls dash
hall here and see what we've got you can
see that there is a make file right here
so all you type in is make then release
64 just as he had it on there
except we need linux in front of this
linux
dash and once you hit that it should
build this whole
library
you have any errors you'll need to
address those
okay well that literally took forever to
complete and it has gone through
everything so basically what you want to
do
is just go to your terminal go all the
way at the bottom just make sure there's
no errors warnings are fine yeah there
are some warnings no big deal
but just make sure there are no errors
and if there are you have to address
them
maybe you need something maybe you need
to have to get something
i don't know you'll have to you have to
address that individually because there
could be a lot of different things but
in general as long as you have the gcc
compiler and you've got the sub modules
correct or you've cloned these correctly
and they're on in the same directory it
should succeed
so once it succeeds we can go to the
next part now what we're going to do
here is uh
update our cmake and what i got here is
uh
if it's unix we're going to leak the
libraries well gl and x11
because those are going to be needed for
the rendering since we're on linux we're
going to go ahead and
set it up for opengl you can also do
vulkan if you want but
i'm not going to get into that i'm not
sure if it works correctly
so we're going to stick with gl so we're
definitely going to need those
we have target link directories
that's going to be the sub mods folder
bgfx build
linux 64 gcc bin basically if we go to
bgfx
we'll see a build.build folder gcc bin
and that's where it's storing all the
libraries so we just need to set
target link directory so can actually
find them
and what we're going to do next here is
we check the build type
if it's debug we're going to link the
debug libraries and
before it goes ahead and links them it
makes sure that
at least one of them exists
so this is just another if not exists if
the debug
based debug library doesn't exist then
i'll throw an error
and if it does we're going to go ahead
and link them now we could do further
checks to check the rest of these and
make sure they're built
they should be though let's just scroll
over a little bit and see what we got
uh live bx live b image live bgx
i don't think the net one's in here yeah
that must be separate so i'm going to
delete this net one
don't really need the net that would be
a whole separate thing
so that links the debug if your
project's set to debug and this one
links the release if your project is set
to
release and it yeah i put a little
message in here go to vgf folder and run
make linux release we just built the
release one so that's what we're gonna
mess with
but you can also build a debug one and
that works fine
too now i'm going to set my cmake build
to release
that way it used the right one and i
gotta fix a few more things here
there we go and i also put an else in
here
so if you're not on unix it's just gonna
i have another fatal error and say
this is only for linux right now
basically what's on your hard drive
now that we've got that all built the
next step is to actually
implement it in your main to pop up a
window start rendering things make an
object
this is a little complicated
you might want something like glfw as
another sub module to do your windowing
and stuff
but you can just take advantage of
whatever os you're using and here in
bgfx
if you go down to examples you'll see
0 0 all the way up to 42
and these are examples that should work
now you'll notice if you go to any of
these like let's look at this hello
world
he's using common bgfx utils logo
now these are the logos right here the
rest of the stuff is actually
in common down here in the samples
folder
so if you want to use those as well
either have to build this common library
or
well i'll figure it out and i'll get you
an example
okay so probably what you want to do at
this time is change directory
into the runtime and run some of the
examples
uh this is something that is in the
documentation but what you do
is you just change directory i'm already
there but i'm gonna go back a few
so if you're on your project root here
just this bgfx project
you want to change directory and just
start typing in when you go to sub mods
vgfx you know wherever you have it built
examples
run time run time
so this runtime area is where you should
be
if you're running any examples because
it has all the resources
in it but do an ls you just see
something i guess i can do it this way
you can see them better but it has fonts
images measured
message shaders all that stuff so what
you do here
is you just do a run of any of the
examples
and then the build you build it for
and then bin examples
and you'll see a few there's a few that
have built automatically
come on get the cursor into the terminal
it will run this draw stress
and it's got i am gui running
now just real quick i want to see if
there's anything else able to be ran
okay this says all of them i guess it's
the hello world there's the cubes okay
so i guess you just want to build
examples release and then you can switch
between them all
with this little program here you can
see
all the examples
and this one okay there it is just here
for a minute but
it looks like we had a segmentation
fault on that one
who knows it might be something to do
with my driver my video card i could
tell you
should be able to get some good examples
going there
it has it all ready and ready to be
linked so
here it is all linked to my main bgfx is
linked
the image is linked bx is linked and my
main is ready to be programmed up and do
stuff with bgfx
all right interjecting with a few other
hot tips so anytime you change cmake at
all
like type 1 character make one space it
runs again so if you're doing things
like file copies and you have a typo
it's going to just redo all the
it's garbage so what you want to do is
just hit ctrl
shift comma and yeah search for
configure cmake and uncheck
this configure on edit because it's
going to ruin your life it is driving me
nuts
okay after what has been uh a lot of
work in googling and figuring things out
i've got
one of the samples to run in my own
main dot cpp and i'm going to show you
how to do that i hope you
i really hope you upload this video and
share it or whatever
any kind of support because this is this
has not been
exactly fun all right so here's what i
had to do to get one of the samples
running in my own main
uh where do i even start so i decided
i'm just going to go
i'll start from the beginning i decided
i was going to try to get
the example zero one cubes into my own
main
so i literally just went to this cpp
copied the whole file
with ctrl a select all control
c to copy all so copy grab the whole
thing copy the whole thing
and get out of this and go to my
main.cpp and i just pasted it in
so one of the things i had to do and
this is a hack
i found out by doing some google google
foo
on github even it needs this underscore
main
because somewhere in one of these
libraries or something it
it needs a reference to this underscore
main underscore so you do have to
put this on the bottom of the file as
well
and that scene yeah that seems to be a
hack even in the code itself
it is mentioned as a hack so
i guess i'll just show that if i can
even find it holy crap i've googled so
many things
yeah here we go someone else had the
problem
undefined reference to maine as someone
said i eventually just put
this somewhere regular next to my
regular main to make the file happy
yeah so and then creator closed it
but i also searched through google and
he
is apparently doing it through a lua
input somewhere so that's a whole nother
realm of things
so that's one thing you got to do is you
got to put that in there and in my
let's see in my cmake i had to add some
things so here's what i did in my cmake
to get it all working
so uh let's see i'm gonna narrow this
down
so the rest is still the same now i had
to do
some includes so this is something i
kind of glazed over
earlier you definitely need to do some
includes to your project you need the
sub modules
uh bgfx bx and b image you need those
all included
but also if you're gonna use any of
these examples he uses some third-party
stuff so you also need to
uh include uh third-party and examples
common
since he uses stuff from those all right
and i also needed to include a few or a
link a few new things i needed to link p
thread and the dl lives and dl lives is
through a macro like so
and p threads is just p thread so those
need to be added to the link libraries
in general
now this is where it gets really tricky
and i didn't set up the debug one but it
would be the same just with debug
so in the release you also need b image
underscore decode release an example
common release an example glue release
of course you could do the debug
versions of those up there if
you're doing those i suppose i could
just go ahead and add those
uh like a boss
like a boss yeah
in case anybody does a debug build
and uh so that was the big thing getting
all those in there that took care of all
the linker errors and also last but not
least i did a
file copy to copy all the run time stuff
into my cmake binary dir that way when i
go
into my build directory over here and i
actually
run where is it my bgfx
project executable it sees all that
stuff
so uh finally
yeah i did a change directory into my
build here as you can see
and type in the bgfx project and
actually run it
so there you go using similar methods
you should be able to get any of these
examples running and
if you run into more linker errors when
you're running something else
[Music]
uh well you might need to link other
things do some googling on what to link
but in general you can find all the
stuff all the different linkers for vgfx
under this build bin and anything that
uses a dot a
so there's that decode release that we
had to include
so if you're using a project that uses
encode you'll have to include that one
and so on in the order of these does
matter
like i noticed if i put glue below the
common release it would not work
so common's gonna be done before glue
and that's just his windowing stuff i'm
not using any external windowing library
i'm just using what he's got here and i
believe that comes with common and glue
so that's it hopefully that gets you
going look for the link below
to this source code i will upload it and
uh
once again thank you for watching hope
you have some luck
getting this up and going it is been a
lot of work to to make this tutorial so
i hope you like it
and uh peace out guys
you